hi guys I'm Greg and I'm John John yes
I'm Isis or did I talked about upstream
junkies news little america film being
produced by Michael Bay directed and
written by Rowan Atkinson that's right
mr. bean is going to happen row at eight
italie or eight hail at hale you call
Rowan for the rest of this video Solly I
talked about it on an extreme yoga new
co-star was there and you signor was
there then that key was there was great
six minute video there's a couple of
things I wanted to add it and I wanted
to hear what John had to pay to but you
know you're live you got to keep it on a
time crunch as four of us on the panel
can't get everything in but you guys not
heard about this give you a breakdown go
fast it's from the hollywood reporter
described by sources as a size 10 story
rather than syfy the tailless set it
afire continue constantly with the
interruptus i fund this Hut the tail is
set in a dystopian future where a Donald
Trump like President as bankrupt America
and China has called in its debts the
Asian giant now owns the US and many
Americans have emigrated to China
looking for work in this new world a
former American Force Recon members
hired by a Chinese billionaire to go
into an American ghetto and rescue his
daughter sources have said it is in the
tone of escape for New York the 1981
John Carter film that starred Kurt
Russell all right okay head up and lock
out starring Guy Pearce yes exactly yeah
there's some good at paying feeling on
the SJ news panel one thing i want to
add I didn't get a chance to enter
there's I think this is great marketing
haha I'm sure this plan like this move
is gonna make a lot of money just
hearing that yeah it's a movie like if
you look at it from the expected of
being American this is something
Americans like really fear we're gonna
be number one we're gonna hustle
surrender to China for it
secure we better well since the
beginning of time apparently are not
only am I remember one day not only a
few hundred years but you know which
Trump being president America going
bankrupt I mean it sounds like that this
script from what I heard has been like
going around the circuit for a few years
now so it's written before Trump ever
became president but now is the time now
you're the top of those bond will check
out the American audience there and then
you have it you know taking place in
China at times because a lot of the big
world leaders that we now live with
China a lot of Americans are emigrating
there and China is like the number one
market for international box office
movies that are equal huge Warcraft did
not do well domestically American film
to not do well domestically did super
well in China so they're going to
actually make a sequel you combine these
few countries together where the topic
of China and instead of like doing a
comic with where we were like we gotta
go to China for like 25 minute we have
to get that Chinese well maybe it are we
mention the China yeah they're nearby
and we want their money exactly exactly
so I feel like this don't really make a
lot of money put Michael Bay's name on
it as a producer I don't think Michael
Bay's reputation is a tampered with in
other countries it is America value of a
michael bay's name in there and it's a
sci-fi story that way I think we all can
get on board with I mean what John what
do you think of this I don't have no
idea what to think I mean this just
sounds very much like it is escape from
new york basically and um I saw the game
could be fun I I guess it's a little
kooky to me right now it's a little bit
of like oh wow I'm Lou the bride they're
talking about this but uh well I showed
you the trailer of Rowan at Hills or a
fail whatever asali I don't know so um I
guess don't there's no accent on the e
athol don't let's say all come across
like unico que sale what you think of
the truth because when I got rhythm
right yeah it looks like yeah it looks
like a cool guy ritchie film like it
looked framed cool and it didn't look
too like it kind of made me feel a
little better about this just because
like you show me the power rangers
trailer like
Power Rangers trailer looks just like a
Michael Bay movie and watching the
trailer for wastelander or what is the
rise that did not look just like a
Michael Bay movie to me like it had like
a cool style to where I got the
interested in seeing that guy do escape
from you yeah yeah I wonder how much can
explore because it says a Chinese
billionaire to go is hired by a Chinese
billionaire to go into an American get
it ok so its not New York it's gonna be
like all of America and he's looking for
this one person well it's an American
ghetto right I can't tell if that's like
in America a nitro in China like America
town or is it as good marriage I don't
know what that means is it too ghetto in
America or if it's you know a ghetto of
like an American refugees or something
like that Nina oh really what do you say
sona takes place in China I sounds like
if someone happened yeah yeah it's like
I can't exactly tell what the the
context of setting will be like but it
schools almost to you know to have that
be have us have Americans be the ones
you know just struggling to get by and
in the socio-cultural ghetto I love how
like when we do like historical fiction
a lot of it is like horrible things
about like Nixon time period you know I
watchmen Nixon time period and we're
already getting that with Trump yeah
we're wasting no time I think just
because that became possible people were
like we gotta start writing right out
something is the matter on the panel
days they wanted us to do a dreamcast
and Matt kisa Idris Elba sexy American
force recon dude the hero ok sure I you
know is your supper would be cool before
we film the name rank off and got tossed
around about us up ova think running off
and can do anything i think james mcavoy
be pretty sweet sure yeah come on i see
a better actor Ryan Gosling haha I can't
see Ryan Gosling concise fun I can see
him in sci-fi but i could see i could he
james mcavoy and psyphon yes you know
especially if he got the crowd beefier
do is supposed to be fun yeah a bit I
saw like okay Trump like president I
originally was a good thing on the panel
i would say do I Alec Baldwin bulges
were flooded I said Mel Gibson I
come up with a zinger what Mel Gibson
would say Andrew from the movie source
channel texted me saying you should have
said give me back my country ransom
that's the line give me back my son the
country in this who would i cashed in
this I don't Guy Pearce I think Scarlett
Johansson would be way it was the girls
scarlett johansson and stephen young
even young yeah i was thinking about
reenactor to play a chinese sidekick
that's like rush hour meets escape from
new york man that's what people wanted
to see for years see I'm bad at casting
off the top of my head and I know I'm
going to think of like the perfect
choices like once we get out of the
typing on Ron Perlman Louie CK
everything James Franco running out of
actual awesome American actors just cast
her rustled son good day just go realize
there he is a real life it's pretty good
too i didn't really like you know i use
funny in 22 jump street but that's like
mere episode ii haha are you excited for
the michael bay produced sigh fun
thriller gate from china this came from
china little bit let's escape from a
little America's a movie called little
america so I'm like is this gonna take
place in like the America town in China
you know that would be boring I doubt
would be different have you boring you
would be boring in America and even like
it's gone bankrupt and all these people
are emigrating in China and it takes
place in America town and chai come on
let's go to a funny little a marriage to
take place is ruined America weaning
little me we're not a giant like
powerful country and you but what about
like Little Tokyo or like that thats my
name of 55 [ __ ] wasn't that America is
in ruins them yes so we created a little
American why Kareena why would we create
a little america town after American
route at there's like this whole crazy
doin am amazed they make I'm just
impossible it's a conclusion that you
know John easily drive ignore would
totally pick me for this I don't
ya know that you're naming the movie
after the town you have to go to ok look
this is all good take place haha look is
a middle America sale salvador goes into
ruin and then they come to America like
all the [ __ ] in England a little El
Salvador and then we have it takes place
in little el salvador instead of going
to the ruins of El Salvadorian for a
sci-fi movie you could do either it's
interchangeable but I don't want to see
a sci-fi movie about a little town in
China I'd rather go to the actual
American ghetto it's about the world
though is it not it's still that version
of the future maybe I will see the
destroyed America at some point but like
something different that does not exist
is a little America inside of China what
are all the American people live why
would a Chinese Willian air rated they
need to hire an American Soybean rehan
and Enver what would my automatic video
with the marriott oh my god you're just
you're you're really just you're turning
the butter I'm just saying it's not an
outlandish conclusion to draw we very
well might see future America because
America has been toppled and it is
little but little America sounds more to
me like the name of a town than an
assertion that America is small now
because it owns China a lot of month
yeah that sounds like a really exciting
plot that's not a plot that I just
didn't ask you I just explained your
interpretation and mine side by side
uh-huh I'm excited to maybe see if this
is going to be an alright movie and the
trailers of michael van you can
subscribe to the real rejects you follow
this [ __ ] on instagram and twitter at
reasons and sherry is also the social
media manager for facebook.com slash
bloom house on a wife at your creative
studio hire this dumbass those of the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash the real reject